[Music]
on this Wednesday night promises for
action on long-term care
Ontario's government assumes control of
five more private care facilities I want
eyes and ears in the homes that were
most worried about as more heartbreaking
stories emerge I got a panic call from
the nurse saying that my mother is not
breathing the calls for accountability
on caring for our elders breaking news a
major legal loss a pivotal decision
about huawei's CFO degree and amplified
calls for justice the world witnessed
murder anger intensifies over the death
of a black man handcuffed and pinned to
the ground by a white officer
global national with Donna freezin
good evening and thanks for joining us
there's another report from the military
tonight on grim conditions inside some
Canadian long-term care homes this one
is from Quebec where soldiers were
called in to help in 25 homes
overwhelmed by kovat 19 the report is 60
pages long though not as detailed about
the shortcomings as were exposed in
Ontario care homes yesterday
it says soldiers witnessed some
exceptionally difficult situations
including staffing shortages problems
with PPE and issues with how residents
with kovat 19 are handled Ontario's
premier Doug Ford today promised swift
action to remedy the deplorable
deplorable conditions found in some
homes he announced more inspections and
said the government is taking over
management of five more of Ontario's
hardest hit facilities in the face of
these problems will use every tool at
our disposal and that means staying on
top of the situation in these homes we
need boots on the ground I want eyes and
ears in the homes that were most worried
about keeping a close watch right now
soldiers have been the only outside eyes
and ears and advocates for the elderly
say what they exposed is terrible but
not new failings in long-term care
especially inadequate staff and low pay
are long-standing the pandemic has made
pre-existing problems worse there remain
active outbreaks in 199 long-term care
homes in Ontario and 131 long-term care
homes in Quebec will get to Ontario and
demands for accountability in just a
moment but we begin with Mike Armstrong
and quebec's care home crisis soldiers
have been working in this Montreal
seniors residence for more than a month
and we now know how it's going according
to the report released Wednesday
almost every single day there's some
sort of an incident that disrupts the
routine now what that means exactly we
don't know the military is reported to
Quebec long-term care facilities is
quite different than the one for Ontario
whereas that one listed incidents some
of them horrifying
quebec document is more of a situation
report it gives the staffing and
infection rates for each of the 25
residences where soldiers are working
and then as a section for comments most
of those comments flag issues with
communication management PPE and
discipline and a critical shortage of
staff patients rights advocates say not
much of it is surprising there are not
enough staff and anyone who's had a
loved one in long-term care will tell
you that we lack training and we lack
supervision what the military are
observing is the result the crisis
didn't start the VEX premier says he
didn't learn much from the report most
of the problems he says are the result
of what he calls embarrassing staff
shortages that existed before kovat 19
but were made worse by it the army was
supposed to be a month-and-a-half
stopgap but that gap is still there I've
asked mr. Trudeau this morning if we can
keep people from the army until
September 15 Laveau says he needs the
soldiers in place while new staff is
trained the province is going on a
hiring binge with significantly higher
wages new orderlies for example would
start at close to $50,000 a year now
it is also staffing that's being blamed
by unions for the awful conditions
flagged in the Ontario report they say
workers don't have enough time to give
proper care and they fear for their jobs
if they go public with what's going on I
know that frontline workers want to do
more and speaking out for themselves in
the conditions but they live under this
reign of terror in fear the question now
is how these two reports might affect
the relationship between soldiers and
civilian staff could there be resentment
the troops are being seen as
whistleblowers my carbs for Global News
Montreal these military reports have
exposed failings on many levels
David akin is looking into
accountability tonight David yeah well
Donna let's start with those Ontario
facilities that were flagged in that
Canadian Forces report remember there
are investigations underway and they
will find out if the operators or even
some employees violated regulations
perhaps even broke some laws and
could be some serious consequences an
operator could see their license pulled
there could be fines maybe even jail
time and as you heard the premier has
ramped up a surveillance program this is
going to affect not just the 20 homes
identified as hotspots
but at all homes in Ontario all 626 with
an enhanced inspection routine and then
there's the political accountability the
premier today saying that an independent
commission is going to get underway in
July and that Commission is going to
have the power to compel testimony from
the premier and anyone in cabinet it
sounds very much to me like the premier
wants some answers when we have the
auditor we have the corner we have the
police we have an independent commission
I'll tell you there there won't be a
piece of dust on the floor that they
aren't going to be inspecting now the
industry group that represents these
facility operators says the answers are
really pretty clear need more personal
protective equipment need more access to
rapid testing need more money to fix up
the facilities and need more flexibility
when it comes to staffing scarce
resources Donna
David there are problems to varying
degrees in care homes right across the
country is there a role for the federal
government and national standards yes I
think there is in fact it was quite an
appetite for that here in Ottawa today
parliamentarians were talking just
exactly about that saying that Ottawa
should set guidelines and regulations
for facilities right across the country
we asked the prime minister about that
but today he was not prepared to set
himself towards any particular course of
action there will be many important
discussions going forward on how we
establish a better system in Canada and
I'm not going to you know short-circuit
that conversation by putting forward
aggressive proposals right now now I can
tell you Donna that this crisis in our
long-term care facilities is going to be
at the top of the agenda when the Prime
Minister and the Premier's have their
weekly teleconference call tomorrow
evening David akin in Ottawa thank you
the reports from the military are grim
later in the broadcast Jim Jeff sample
speaks with a woman who says she learned
how her mother
died by reading the Ontario report first
a quick note on antibody testing tonight
the American Centers for Disease Control
is urging decision-makers not to rely on
antibody test results to decide on
reopening offices or letting students
gather in schools antibody tests look at
serum in blood for evidence your immune
system has fought off an infection or
virus in the past a positive test means
you could be immune for Cova 19 and in
Tet then the test could help monitor
communities spread but new evidence from
the CDC shows if antibody testing is
carried out in a population where cases
of kovat 19 are low there can be many
false positives and is possible less
than half of those testing positive will
truly have the antibodies a recovery
crew has located the wreckage of the
Canadian Armed Forces helicopter that
crashed off the coast of Greece last
month the remains of fallen
servicemembers were found nearby a
remote operated vehicle located a large
piece of the cyclone helicopters
fuselage it's lying more than 3000
meters below the surface the helicopter
was carrying six Canadian Forces members
from HMCS Fredericton when it went down
on April 29th the u.s. is assisting with
the recovery operation and an
investigation into the crash is ongoing
the remains of just two of the victims
have been positively identified so far a
big decision NBC's Supreme Court today
Huawei executive hmong wong jo lost the
first round of her attempt to avoid
extradition to the United States where
she's accused of fraud and violating
sanctions against Iran the decision
rests on the concept of double
criminality essentially that a crime in
the u.s. must be a crime here as well
it means moong Wong Jo stays put under
house arrest in Vancouver and it
ratchets up the tension between Canada
and China which is accused Canada of
being an accomplice of the United States
Robin Gill explains the ruling Moin Wong
Jo did not have a look of defeat going
into BC Supreme Court but this wasn't to
be heard a fraud is brought that is the
heart of the decision despite having
hired some of the best and most
expensive legal minds in
the Hmong lost round one associate chief
justice Heather Holmes ruled the effects
of the US sanctions may properly play a
role in the double criminality analysis
in other words the charges she faces in
the United States would stand in Canada
the CFO of Huawei and the daughter of
its founder is accused of misleading
American banks by neglecting to disclose
a subsidiary company called sky comm
which did business in Iran the US says
she committed fraud and violated
sanctions against Iran Hmong was
arrested in Canada in December 2018 at
the request of the u.s. her lawyers
argued that Canada didn't have sanctions
with Iran at the time and Hmong should
be let go the crown argued that the
overall allegation of fraud would be
considered a crime in Canada and
therefore she must be extradited Justice
Holmes sided with federal lawyers Ms
bangs approach to the double criminality
analysis would seriously limit Canada's
ability to fulfill its international
obligations in the extradition context
for fraud and other economic crimes
Huawei Canada issued a statement that
the company was disappointed and
repeatedly expressed confidence in miss
monks innocence Huawei continues to
stand with Miss Hmong in her pursuit for
justice and freedom Hmong still has
other legal maneuverings there's a civil
suit against the RCMP and border
security alleging that during the arrest
they questioned her without her lawyers
present and took possession of her
electronic devices they're betting the
farm on the Charter argument next one's
team says there are still other legal
rounds to go so there isn't an appeal
just yet so she won't be taking off the
electronic monitoring anklet that has
become an accessory and a condition of
her bail hmong is paying for her own
security while she's under house arrest
here in Vancouver and it doesn't look
like she's going anywhere especially to
China anytime soon
Donna Robin Gill in Vancouver thanks so
much is resting on this case beyond the
fate of Hmong Wong's show Canadians
Michael Cove Rick and Michael Spahr have
been detained for more than 500 days in
China without any consular access
since the pandemic began the Chinese
government took them into custody sure
laughter mungs arrest and after today's
ruling China is even more furious
abigail Beeman is in Ottawa with
reaction to the ruling and what happens
next
Abigail Donna China is not happy with
this development in a strongly worded
statement the embassy here in Ottawa
warns Canada not to go further down the
wrong path calling mungs arrests
arbitrary saying the purpose of the
United States is to bring down Huawei
and Canada is an accomplice and calling
the whole case a grave political
incident but whether China chooses to
retaliate and how remains to be seen
initial reports in Chinese media suggest
Canada has lost judicial independence to
the US the Global Times printing it
makes Canada a pathetic clown and a
scapegoat I think that in the cotton
sour soup that is the Canada China
relationship this is added a little bit
more vinegar to that soup and that we
better watch Chinese attitudes carefully
and address them as patiently and
honestly as we can at the heart of this
there is much concern over what happens
to Michael Kovarik and Michael spam or
the two Canadians arbitrarily detained
in the days following mungs arrest
widely viewed as retaliation Abigail
what about the political reaction have
we heard from the Canadian government
well the Foreign Affairs Minister issued
a statement in response to the ruling
saying Canada will continue to be
transparent about the extradition
process and advocating for the release
of culver against Pawar saying that
continues to be Canada's top priority no
comment from justice Minister David
linetti today and the Prime Minister has
been clear about letting our independent
justice system performance duty but
that's been a big sticking point with
Beijing which doesn't subscribe to the
rule of law and now we're one step
closer to the justice minister having to
make a decision in this case whether to
send hmong to the United States but this
is a long road with many legal steps to
go through first including potential
appeals it's critical that we are clear
and resolute in communicating our
principles and as part of that our
commitment to the rule of law
how in canada the extradition process is
based on law not on not on politics so
potentially more pressure added to
Canada China relations but in terms of
Ottawa and Washington we got a statement
from the US Department of Justice
Banking Canada for its continued
assistance in this matter
donna abigail Beeman in Ottawa thank you
advocates for China here in Canada are
back in the headlines today over using
government supported forums to try and
influence the public a WeChat social
media group run on behalf of digital
government Minister Joyce Murray was
used to crowd source funding for a
lawsuit against a global news journalist
he helped expose Chinese state-backed
efforts to stockpile coronavirus safety
supplies today the Liberal MP from BC is
being criticized and pressured to
apologize for allowing it to happen
Conservative MP Rosemarie Falk pressed
the issue in the House of Commons and
the Public Safety Minister came to
Murray's defense as one of the one of
the principles with strong democracy a
commitment to defend freedom of
expression with the Liberals hold Joyce
Murray's WeChat accountable if it has
violated this part of the Charter I
think has been the Minister has made
very clear she was not involved in this
process and them and has no control over
the individual that hosted that matter
Joyce Murray's communication team says
the WeChat post was unacceptable and in
no way reflects the minister's views the
u.s. president's latest threats coming
up why he's targeting social media
platforms
there are demands for police officers in
Minneapolis who were fired yesterday
be charged with murder they were
involved in the arrest of an
african-american man who died on Monday
thousands of people flooded the streets
today near the spot where George Floyd
died late yesterday the demonstrations
became violent and officers used tear
gas and rubber bullets
a bystander recorded the arrest it shows
an officer who is white
using his knee to keep George Floyd
pinned to the ground you can hear him
say please I can't breathe he died
shortly after this both the FBI and
state law enforcement are now
investigating his death the American
president who loves to use Twitter is
now lashing out at social media
platforms after Twitter fact-checked
one of his tweets Donald Trump says
Republicans filled Twitter and other
platforms
silence conservative voices today he
threatened to strongly regulate them or
shut them down Twitter he tweeted has
now shown that everything we have been
saying about them is correct
big action to follow Twitter for the
first time used a fact check label on
one of trumps tweets with a link to
information debunking his claims about
mail-in voting fraud twitter says the
messages contain potentially misleading
information and have been labeled to
provide additional context it's a
response to long-standing criticism
Twitter's
- hands off when it comes to policing
misinformation and falsehoods including
from world leaders like Trump
still ahead she discovered the truth of
his mother's death by reading it in a
military report
it's been more than two months that
families of residents and long-term care
homes have been unable to visit their
loved ones the agonizing wait was made
worse by those military reports on the
grim conditions they found inside some
homes in Ontario and Quebec those
soldiers are the only outside eyes and
ears allowed into care homes and their
reports make devastating reading
especially for families with relatives
inside jeff sample has spoken to some of
them almost every day for two months
Michael swans has waited outside this
long-term care home hoping to see his 93
year old mother through her fourth story
window
I hope for the best and I just beam as
much positive energy as I came towards
the people in the place inside it but
when he read the military's report from
inside this and for other care homes the
whole document was disappointing and it
felt like a punch in the gut his mother
tested positive for kovin 19 a couple of
weeks ago but she's pulled through
others have not this is a picture of my
mom dude Pamela Bendel's 90 year old
mother June suffered from Parkinson's
and dementia and couldn't speak staff at
her care home were told she needed to be
sitting up to eat and drink or she could
choke Bendel even posted a photo with
arrows and instructions on the wall next
to her bed all you had to do was look at
that picture and I had have a line to
say pillow goes here it was very clear
but on May 8th something went wrong I
got a panic call from the nurse saying
that my mother is not breathing her
death was ruled an accident it wasn't
until she saw the military's report that
alleged staff weren't always sitting
residents up which appeared to have
contributed to a patient's death I went
on now your website and read it and I
went that's my mom it's frustrating I
mean your mother at 90 years old doesn't
deserve to die like that
Bendel actually worked as a personal
support worker at the same home in the
80s her mother had been living here for
10 years
Bendel says she would find her covered
in bruises once with a broken toe
she says this care home was understaffed
and
sourced before the pandemic I just think
it's impossible for any that few love
people to take care of the needs that
these people require you just do the
bare minimum so these are all things
leading up to the pandemic and then the
pandemic have others with family members
still inside these homes like Flo
Tomkinson missing her 87 year old
husband and wondering if she'll see him
again it's obviously on lockdown and has
been for a very long time and there
doesn't seem to be a way out
Geoff sample Global News Toronto
launched let down next the space
milestone that's been postponed
Elon Musk will have to wait a little bit
longer thanks to some bad weather in
Florida today in Dragon SpaceX
unfortunately we are not going to launch
today at t-minus 16 minutes the launch
of his SpaceX rocket carrying two
American astronauts was called off when
it happens it will be the first ever
commercial space flight to ferry humans
into orbit part of NASA's plan to have
private companies serviced the
International Space Station and beyond
the SpaceX Dragon is one of two private
spacecraft under development for NASA
right now SpaceX and NASA will try again
on Saturday and that is global national
for this Wednesday I'm Donna Friesen
we'll leave you tonight with a Canadian
countdown in five days more than half of
Canada's national parks will reopen for
day use Parks Canada closed all the
sites in March because of Ko bid 19 on
June 1st 29 of our 48 National Park
sites will reopen with safety measures
and physical distancing rules giving
Canadians a chance to get closer to
nature and closer to normal thanks for
watching
hope to see you here again tomorrow take
care of yourselves bye bye
[Music]
you